- I'm gonna give you the
best piece of advice I got.
You need to,
more than anything,
think about two core
things in my opinion.
- One, you have to
at all costs not beat
your own self up with yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] At all costs.
- [Woman] Fair enough.
It's huge.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] You need to really be
your own biggest fan instead of
critiquing everything.
Number two, moments in time.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- You've got to
wrap your head around
how young you actually are.
You have to wrap your
head around how early in the
process this is and how this
is just a very
small moment in time.
- [Woman] Yeah.
Very quickly I can tell you you
need to get every voice out of
your head besides yourself
and you need to love yourself.
You will win.
Can't live your life based on
other people's point of view.
(light music)